okay we are here in the Google
self-driving car very inside it's
obviously driving itself
and it's doing everything by itself and
I am here as a passenger I'm really
hoping that Sebastian did a good job of
training this because he's not driving
right now and I'm not driving if it
drives better than me I am at the mercy
of this car and that's true it does try
that why are we talking about seven cars
here why are we talking about
self-driving cars well we're going to
start by talking about supervised
classification and self-driving cars are
one big supervised classification house
supervised mean supervised means that
you have a bunch of examples where you
know sort of the correct answer in those
examples so I know that you have an
example of this from the self-driving
cars yeah so I mean we train our car and
we show the car what's the right
behavior when we did the DARPA Grand
Challenge we would take it off for spin
and it would very carefully wash us
human drivers drive and would emulate
our behavior and in fact this is sort of
how people learn to drive right yeah I
think so when I was a child I watched my
parents drive and they weren't
pathetical drivers but I could still
copy a lot of stuff from them yeah so
it's kind of like in the way the humans
drive by watching lots of examples
that's what computers do when they're
doing machine learning is you give them
lots of examples and they start to
figure out what's going on yeah that's
what we'll be learning about and that's
so neat win this unit you're going to be
learning about machine learning the same
way we pull in self-driving car you're
going to program in data and and test
out whether you can make a car go fast
and slow or the appropriate time using
machine learning supervised learning
that's right so we're going to be
looking at a really cool terrain
classification problem that was very
important for Stanley you want to
introduce that so in Stanley's case I
would strike with the desert and the
desert terrain has like ruts and
Berman's can be very brutal so if you
drive too fast you're running risk of
flipping over and destroying yourself so
one thing we trained the car to do is to
really slow down the appropriate time we
did is not about dividing the rules you
did it by us demonstrating the car how
we drive and it was just emulators how
many miles did you have to drive to
train that
Oh a thousands of miles we spent
thousands of my it's every day in the
desert and it took quite a vibrate the
car being smart your poor grad students
yeah well I was to go where the pizza
for everybody but it was a great time
because it was no email we just had us
on the software and every time you got a
software back it was very obvious think
I would punish us oh that sounds great
so I think we should probably get
started with that let's try out a few
different supervised classification
problems yeah so the unit is all about
to bow is knowing so let's dig in sounds
great